hello everybody's on one McClung key
means my flunky yeah you know what
McClatchy means don't you like secretly
do you know secretly know what it means
you know the Han shot first burrito
scene yeah when they rerelease it on
Disney plus burrito now says McClung key
well could mean anything okay now we are
at the culmination of the Skywalker saga
JJ what was the bigger challenge
starting this trilogy or wrapping it up
not starting it wrapping it up for sure
because there's nine movies and the
responsibility is much greater and you
know starting something isn't isn't
necessarily easy but it's it's far
easier because you you know the
possibilities of what happens like a
fight or everything it's hard to put out
a fire that's quite true that's actually
good analogy Oscar Isaac please and
gentlemen so for the cast are you guys
satisfied with the way that your stories
wrap up yep our 9 film saga champion
three times I've said goodbye and this
is and then you know what is okay it's
okay it's time it's true Kony is a bit
of a rest I think but he's never gonna
go away he's always gonna be showing to
probably 400 tell me about it
I can put on weight at last think about
yeah wild get this man an Oscar so for
the cast how do you guys commemorate
wrapping up this saga do we get group
tattoos do we steal from said what do we
do go dragons all that stuff gold jacket
state like animation yeah right the
world
exactly I'm glad you guys are sitting
together back together I really liked
her video John who filmed that that was
just on your own to make sure that all
goes well
and we we have a lot of fun with each
other on that and I think it's good to
be able to show that side and while I
was in Berlin I just saw a table that
looks very old-school so I call my t1
cake all this be a great job write a
[Laughter]
letter you got it now speaking of which
you guys have so much fun together but
in this film we're finally getting the
trio to have an adventure together can
you guys talk about what that felt like
does it feel like kind of bringing the
franchise full circle I was just happy
to get out of the cockpit for a little
while been sequestered in space so it
was for me that was one of the most
exciting things when I read the script
that
get together you get to see the dynamic
between three of us and I think the
natural chemistry that we all share
together and then also the way that JJ
let us play within those scenes and shot
those scenes of that there was a lot of
yeah yeah it's just yeah a lot of
improvisation and excitement and talking
over one another so you really felt that
we were connected yeah I think was fun
okay nothing back back for me anyway is
Star Wars like you're not famous far
Walt until people see you as a trio and
it was important in this one for me like
that we were together just as sure that
chemistry and to show what I've always
enjoyed about Star Wars which is the
connection between between people
I'm beginning to feel a trio was I not
there I was the one in gold and it felt
good
JJ decided to give me a role in this
film didn't she change it I love any
time Anthony Daniel seizes the moment
like absolutely my moment to shine okay
I can't talk about this film without
talking about Carrie Fisher is there a
piece of advice that she gave one of you
guys that sticks out if anybody has
anything that comes to mind I remember
you were telling me one time she just
tells you to break your diet
[Laughter]
laughs Jedi and I was hungry as hell and
Carrie had a can of coke next to it and
I was looking at it and she was just
like you know what what why you why you
looking at my kind of coke my sidewall
because I'm I haven't had sugar in the
last like three four weeks and I'm
marina Rita craving and she said go to
my trailer besides some signs and few
figures because she had some figures
that she was giving out no no she was
giving out to fans or whatever I signed
a few of them and then getting my fridge
and they were kick cats Snickers Twix I
mean Billy man we went through the whole
thing my face was a little rounded the
c3pr means the road trip good yeah well
there was no one with better stories
yeah then Carrie I mean her wit and her
she had this amazing ability to do these
kind of free associative like almost
like riddles as she spoke I mean she was
just an incredible incredibly brilliant
and obviously you know hysterically
funny soul and and so to have her around
it wasn't so much advice that she gave
as it was just through these offhand
comments that were like it would often
make you gasp like she would just say
the things that you know she'd love to
shock and she was just you know a
sweetheart and we all love and miss her
well in the first few minutes that I met
her she immediately started talking
about like
ex-husbands and all his stuff and then
she stopped in the middle of it and said
sorry I can't do small talk for me it's
like the way that she interacted with us
and the world is the advice you know
it's like how to lead with yourself and
not to be afraid of you know saying the
wrong thing or trying to conform to
something you know that's what's so
great about caring I love that I love
that we saw some footage from behind the
scenes of the new movie and I feel like
there's always cameos oh yeah this is oh
[Applause]
my lord very committed when it's morning
four years ago yeah and I just like I
always wanted one and then I was like I
don't want it here there and then it's
like you're married to the rebellion it
kind of is yeah thank you
okay well behind the scenes we've seen
we've seen cameos from a bunch of
celebrities like a storm troopers ed
Sheeran Daniel Craig was a rumor for a
little bit
Lyudmila Miranda is there anyone that
you can reveal that maybe we never knew
they had a cameo or weren't any of those
not true they're ones that we don't know
well Daniel Craig was a stormtrooper in
the force awakens and like a real proper
like yeah I can remember that one I'm
like really good
[Laughter]
there are some people but their names
I'd rather not give out before the movie
comes out hmm
you probably well but it's also the
weird thing and even no income for
Carrie and Naomi welcome to Star Wars
very I mean those costumes are just out
of this world for both of you what was
the moment because I feel like this is
kind of a cliche question but the moment
you step on sad or maybe get the script
or find out your character's name where
you're like oh I'm in Star Wars what was
that moment for you and I'm not giving
anything away because I could have just
been there watching or participating but
there was this moment when I saw this
huge group of stormtroopers go past like
in the uniform or like in formation and
I was like once it was like cut and then
like people are milling around like
there was you know you see a lot of
different like stormtroopers and aliens
and stuff like that and then people are
just like chillin having a diet coke can
you're like oh this is the best probably
that I would agree yeah but also it's
something that doesn't actually ever
finish because I forget on a daily basis
and then I do things like this at this
point it feels difficult to feel any
kind of ownership over this because it's
just so massive and it means so much and
there's such a it's just a such a
cultural phenomenon that you know to
even feel like any of it belongs to
you know I it just doesn't feel that way
you know I yeah surprised and reminded
of the enormity of it yeah
sorry bull okay so now since we're
graduating kind of from this trilogy
we're gonna do a little bit of
superlatives there's only a couple who
here is most likely to make a lightsaber
or blaster sound while filming I think
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
as long as we get our Finn Wu in this
movie okay
cast member most likely to get to make
another cast member break on set you do
things with your eyebrows most likely to
drop a spoiler in an interview just
trying to get some trouble
Kelly and lastly most likely to have a
script but for the Porsche awakens
Stasia John you guys have this amazing
rap that I still remember we're all up
in the desert gonna film it's on Apple
and a fight is is there a wrap-up song
pun intended for this trilogy in the
works
no but we could get in the studio and
lay something down we can Bremen ate on
it over the next couple weeks I want to
see a full standout performance at one
of these premieres demanded a London
premiere okay I'll have to come thank
you guys so much
[Music]